well I've always I've always said to
people who because so many people when I
go to panels are conditioned not the
question that I'm sure all three of us
get asked is how do you start a YouTube
chat like what tips do you have for a
beginning YouTube channel and I've
always said to people that the moment
you start getting dislikes in your video
is when you know you've made it or you
[ __ ] up you know if your videos start
to get maybe like one or two dislikes
like you know yeah
maybe 10 times the amount of lies yeah
then that means you know you've made it
because now you're reaching a wide
enough audience that you won't be able
to please everybody and and that's the
end goal really for content creators
because I think it's kind of futile that
there are some content creators out
there who are just really desperate to
try and please everybody and I always
just want to tell those people dude it's
it's not gonna work like you just have
to accept that if you're on the Internet
people are gonna hate you for no reason
and you just have to accept that yeah
like it's I mean you read the comments
right and you see that some people make
really odd conclusions from your
behavior that are really just in general
and someone no matter what you do and
what kind of personality you show one
person is going to perceive it in a bad
way right it's just kind of like like if
we were just to take all the videos
where we've collaborated you know
apparently Connors like manically
depressed I always get this important
you think I'm mad at them but I just
have a face naturally that's just like
there's always that one common win it's
just like why is it why is gonna so
depressed to be there like your English
video okay people like yo Connors not
like super energetic it's like it's not
my video I don't want to be that [ __ ]
he's like it's about me yeah if I'm on
like Jerry's channel right yeah Joey's
tune is intro I'm not gonna try and
interject it's his [ __ ] intro well
yeah I'm not so self-centered where I
think that I'm on someone else's video
that I have to be the center of
attention I'm there to be on Joey's
channel right yeah right I don't see it
as like I need to entertain yeah we're
not all like Guy Fieri
like I'll country when I can join it but
I'm not gonna cut you off
yeah yeah right because you would piss
me off if someone was like trying to
really show me up on my own channel yeah
bro clapping wouldn't it be good right
if you're doing a video with someone
let's say you're a new youtuber and your
friend comes over you're like let's make
a video and your friend is like his
normal self the moment that camera turns
on he's like yo what's up you like that
would be weird right
obviously I'm not like that all that
yeah yeah it's just something that's
like I don't know man